it looks like things might be heating up
for Pete Davidson and Kaia Gerber a
source tells ET that the two spent
Saturday night together at the Saturday
Night Live after-party in New York City
according to the source the two arrived
together and they even rocked matching
90s inspired looks quote throughout the
night they were very affectionate and
flirtatious with one another at one
point in the evening Pete and Kaia were
alone together in the back of the
restaurant in one of the booths they
were laughing with each other and
exchanging flirtatious touches Pete and
Kaia who is the daughter of Cindy
Crawford and Randy Gerber have been
spending a lot of time together
they were first snapped by a fan hanging
out at su Dells restaurant in New York
City that's the 26 year olds comedian
and the 18 year old model sitting in a
corner booth smiling away then Pete was
seen leaving kaya's apartment after a
lunch date soon after that kiyah hit up
a Knicks game with her dad and guess who
else just happened to be there you
guessed it Pete earlier this month the
supermodel raised a few eyebrows when
she was seen wearing this necklace at
the Women's Guild cedars-sinai annual
luncheon in Beverly Hills yeah look a
little closer
that's a P pendant ladies and gents so
do with that what you will since then
the two have engaged in some serious PDA
we're talking hand-holding people that's
the rumored couple outside of a grocery
store in upstate New York I'm still
shook over this love connection and
honestly it's a full-time job keeping up
with Pete's love life just to get you up
to speed in August he and Margaret
quality sparked romance rumors then they
were spotted together a few times in
September he even attended the premiere
of her flick Seberg at the 2019 Venice
Film Festival but their rumored love was
short-lived and fizzled out fast before
Margaret peat was linked to Kate
Beckinsale and while they were hot and
heavy for a hot SEC that fizzled out too
in April a source confirmed e.t that the
pair was still friends but not on
romantic terms then of course there's
who can forget Pete got engaged to
Ariana Grande after less than a month of
dating before calling it off just a few
months later which led to the release of
Ariana's single girl anthem Thank You
next
as for kaya she's kept her dating life
pretty private but she was spotted
earlier this year with model Wellington
grant the two sparked romance rumors in
early February when he posted this pic
to his insta story having a thumb war
with kaya backstage at the Stella
McCartney show they were also seen
cozying up on Valentine's Day before
they were snapped holding hands during a
New York stroll but the last time they
were photographed together was in April
when they grabbed dinner with Caius
famous parents in an interview with
British Vogue in September kaya admitted
that her crazy work schedule didn't
leave a lot of time for love quote when
I'm working I don't have the energy to
even flirt with anyone I'm sorry I just
can't but I'm not losing hope in all
love forever
I definitely leave time to do normal
teenage things and I feel like even
though I have had to miss out on some
things like that normal teenagers do
this makes it all break so we did a
little investigative journalism for you
you're welcome
and get this in June Pete made his
runway debut for Alexander Wang kaya
also walked in that show cute right
you can count on ET to bring you all the
latest deets on Pete and kaya's a
budding romance so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Haley Stephens bye for now
[Music]